[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
prosecutors won't pursue a new death
sentence for convicted wife killer
scott peterson victim lacey peterson's
family saying this process is simply too
painful
jury selection is underway in the
tennessee trial of a father accused of
murdering his autistic son
and disposing of the body why joseph
daniel's defense says his confession
was coerced the accused daytona beach
serial killer appears in court
as prosecutors prepared two death
penalty eligible trials for the murders
of four women
plus bombshell testimony in the trial of
robert durst for the murder of susan
berman
are prosecutors successfully tying the
murder of the millionaire's best friend
to the disappearance of his first wife
she was extremely frightened that
maybe something would happen to her law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to ghost
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
prosecutors in california announced they
won't be seeking a new death sentence
for convicted killer scott peterson
angelina is here with this major
development
brian this came as a little bit of a
surprise well first of all there is a
moratorium on the death penalty
in california but the prosecutor in this
case had
indicated in the past that she would
seek the death penalty yet again
she explained in court documents what
has changed
months after the california supreme
court vacated scott peterson's death
sentence
stanislaus county district attorney
berget flatigar notified the court she
would not seek the death penalty against
scott peterson
at his resentencing flatter wrote while
the family of lacey and connor believe
there is no doubt that the defendant is
guilty of these crimes
the family has decided this process is
simply too painful to endure once again
but it's not been determined whether
peterson will get a new trial
to my mind it's it's all over but the
shouting if
if there was ever a case that needed to
be reversed on the guilt phase that's
the case
attorney mark garrigus represented
peterson at his trial in 2004.
peterson's attorneys say juror rachelle
neese engaged in juror misconduct
she from the outset was not following
the judge's order that you've got to
start all over again discuss she came in
with an agenda and it was clear
the trial court will determine whether
niece's behavior was so egregious that
peterson deserves a new trial
juror mike bell messieri said nice
wasn't a driving force in the
deliberations
she didn't in any way influence anyone
with her her position and his feelings
on the death sentence issue
whether or not he knows the gas chamber
is truly for me in any way
an issue and right now there are really
three issues for scott peterson the
first being whether or not
taxpayers will fund his attorney whether
he gets a public defender or whether
a private attorney is paid for by the
taxpayers that's actually what he wants
he wants pat harris who represented him
in the past
to now represent him again and also we
have the issue of when he will be
resentenced to life without the
possibility of parole and third
whether or not scott peterson gets a new
trial there's been no decision
on that just yet brian thanks
angeannette joining us today is legal
analyst dina doll and terry austin
dean it clearly a move to spare the
victim's family the pain of another
trial
was this the right move though i think
it was the right move because
they're in california and right now
there's the moratorium and before then
it was
very rare for anybody to be put to death
under the death penalty
so the fact that the family also didn't
want to go through with what would have
maybe been a more symbolic
death penalty punishment i think the
process prosecution took that into
consideration when they decide not to
seek it
again now terry the reason why we're
here seems to be a misstep by the trial
court
uh they let peterson basically go with
life without the possibility of parole
rather than death sentence
did the appeals judge get it right
though for overturning that sentence
you know what brian i think the
appellate court did get it right
whether or not you agree with the end
result they kept the core conviction for
now and you know they are saying that
the
death sentence really should be
overturned because
the lower court aired when they
dismissed the jurors who responded
to the questionnaire that they opposed
the death penalty
and i think that the appellate court
made the right decision because there's
no indication that these jurors
weren't going to be fair there's no
indication that they weren't going to
follow
the law so the judge should not have
summarily dismissed those jurors
no angela as you described it it seemed
like there's a lot of moving pieces
here that has yet to be decided for
peterson
so what's next for his cases coming
forward
well really what's next is that decision
on whether or not
he will get a public defender or whether
or not the taxpayers will be forced to
pay
for his private attorney who is pat
harris pat harris
wants to take the case but he also wants
to be paid
and right now scott peterson is indigent
and his family says
they can't pay so that decision is going
to be made
on june 18th and then there will be
another hearing later this month
about the issue on whether or not he
gets a new trial
yeah pretty common occurrence where an
individual you're guaranteed counsel
through the sixth amendment
you can get a public defender or a
private attorney who's funded by the
state
but getting to pick is not something
that really happens
uh tara any additional thoughts you
think might happen in this peterson case
in terms of who his lawyer gets uh
selected as we go forward
you know it's interesting because i
never in a million years ever thought
that he would even be attempting to be
indigent here but i think that if he
gets another lawyer it's going to have
to be someone who
is good on appellate issues because that
is the real issue here whether or not he
should have
a new trial based on that one juror who
everyone is saying was biased and
prejudiced but we'll see at the end of
the day
now andrea do you have some dates for us
i know you said one day earlier about an
appeal
when can we expect a decision on whether
scott peterson gets a new trial
well the the later date this month is
really to discuss the status of that
issue
and things like that so the judge said
during the most recent hearing that
she hopes to have a decision on whether
or not peterson actually gets a new
full-blown blown trial by
the end of 2021 thank you and jeanette
for that and thank you all for
contributing
now to idaho where defense attorneys for
the so-called doomsday couple
have withdrawn their subpoena for a
local reporter
lori valo day bell and her husband chad
dabel are charged with murdering valo's
two children
the bodies of j.j valo and tyler ryan
were found buried on daebel's property
lori's case is on hold pending a mental
health competency evaluation
but chad's attorney previously
subpoenaed east idaho news reporter
nate eaton to appear in court for a
change of venue hearing
the newspaper retained an attorney and
learned this past weekend
attorney john pryor withdrew it the
newspaper called the withdrawal
a welcome recognition of the first
amendment day bell is scheduled to
appear in court for his arraignment on
june 9.
still ahead on law and crime daily is a
serial killer behind
multiple murders of women in florida
over decades
but first how a jury is being selected
in the trial of a tennessee father
who confessed to killing his son and
then recanted
the nobody murder trial next
[Music]
welcome back the jury selection is
underway in the tennessee trial
of a father accused of murdering his
five-year-old son and hiding the body
joseph ray daniels called 9-1-1 on april
4 2018
to report his son as missing daniel said
his five-year-old with autism
joe clyde daniels known as baby joe was
last seen the night before
a search was launched for baby joe in
dickinson county state investigators
were called in
but three days later those investigators
said daniels confessed to murdering his
son
his exact words was he was bleeding but
he said he did not see blood
daniel reportedly said during a five
hour interrogation that he hit baby joey
until the boy stopped crying daniels
described putting the boy in the trunk
of his car
and leaving his body in a field daniels
took investigators to that location
but the five-year-old's body has never
been found daniel has since recanted his
defense says he suffers from mental
health issues
and calls his confession cohorts and you
don't have any
physical evidence outside the the
alleged confession
that the child was killed or carried
anywhere
physical evidence um
i did not collect any i am aware of um
physical evidence related to a shovel
but i'm not aware of that
that's been in any information relating
to that show has been confirmed
investigators say there was no physical
evidence of the child living in the
house
and said it could have been cleaned
before it was searched daniels is
charged with criminal homicide
the boy's mother crystal daniels is
charged with aggravated child neglect or
endangerment
she's also accused of helping to cover
up the crime a judge previously ruled
the two
would be tried separately daniels is the
first to stand trial
jury selection is scheduled for tuesday
and wednesday jurors will be selected
from another county
and will be sequestered during what is
expected to be a one-week trial
opening statements are set for thursday
daniels is being held in jail on a one
million dollar bond
let's bring back legal analyst dina dahl
and terry austin to break down this new
trial
terry this is a new one for us so jurors
are being bus
from a neighboring county and
sequestered how do you think this will
affect the trial
actually i think it's a great idea
judges always have that option but they
don't usually select it i think
picking the jurors from the neighboring
county of hamilton county
is a good idea because maybe they don't
know much about the case
and bussing them back i think is also a
good idea and sequestering them
because if they're in a hotel they can
have control
as far as what news they see about the
case and there's less of a chance that
they will
see something that will affect their
later deliberations so i think it's a
great idea one strange thing about this
case
the judge is having the court being held
in session
on saturdays which is a little bit odd
but maybe he's doing that
because he's decided to keep these
jurors in a hotel
and he wants the case to proceed as
expeditiously as possible
that makes sense see how that plays out
terry just a follow-up does the fact
that daniels
didn't or couldn't bring officers to his
son's body affect the confession because
they're saying there's not much physical
evidence
and we've seen any other trials where
where the defendant brings them to the
body
that's usually used as a way to kind of
show you had knowledge about where this
person
died and how they died so does it affect
the case here
yeah you know what brian if i'm the
prosecutor i would argue that
the fact that the defendant did not
bring us to the body
has no effect on the confession he's
already confessed to killing his child
and you know i would even go further to
say that the defendant is
probably holding out thinking he can use
that information to his advantage
perhaps
down the line at when he's pleading now
dina of course the prosecution's going
to be arguing that but the defense is
going to be saying
five hour course interrogation that led
to no body the defense's argument seems
pretty clear
do you think that could lead them to be
to reasonable doubt though for the end
of this trial
you know it definitely opens up the door
for reasonable doubt because
a you know why didn't he lead them to
the body he's in the middle of
confession he's taking them to a
location
and then also he said that he put his
son in his trunk
and there's no video footage of his car
leaving that night
so you do have to start to wonder i mean
we know something happened to this child
but his mother was also in the ver in
the house that night
you know was it the father or was it the
mother and that's where it starts to
create reasonable doubt could he have
confessed at the time because he was
trying to protect his wife
the fact that you would do this
confession and then
leave out critical details or lie about
critical details within the confession
definitely helps in the defense of their
argument that it was
coerced all right we'll see how it plays
out thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily damning
testimony against real estate heir
robert durst but it's not for the murder
he's on trial for
plus when and where the so-called
daytona beach serial killer will stand
trial for multiple murders
find out next
we're back a suspected serial killer
appeared in person
in a courtroom in one county to be heard
remotely in another
as florida prosecutors work out which of
his death penalty eligible trials
will go first we're here on a status
check
robert hayes is accused of murdering
rachel bay in 2016
by strangling her the palm beach county
sheriff says a rape kit revealed hayes
dna
had we'd not done this we're pretty sure
that he would have killed again
genetic genealogy solved bay's murder
and investigators say linked hayes
to the murder of three more women in
daytona beach from 2005
to 2006. those women had been shot to
death
we have been able to take what we
believe is a serial killer off the
streets
hayes has pled not guilty and wrote in
previous court documents that he claims
investigators withheld cell phone
information
that showed he was in a different area
from the location of the murder
at the same time a witness allegedly
told police he saw
bay alive hayes admits to having sex
with rachel bay that night
but claims he didn't kill her
prosecutors say hayes targeted sex
workers for years
and are seeking the death penalty in
both counties the murders with which mr
hayes has been charged up in volusia
county occurred well before
the murder with which he's charged down
here it probably makes sense for us to
kind of
stay back and and allow that case to
proceed
hayes is scheduled to appear in volusia
county next month for what's known as a
williams hearing
the state is seeking to admit evidence
from bay's case into the murder trials
for the first three known victims
here to talk alleged serial killer with
us is legal analyst dina dahl and
co-host terry austin
now terry williams hearing is used to
admit evidence in
other crimes to show motive intent or
other factors
if the prosecution wins that hearing
here then what next you know what that
would be great news for the prosecution
that hearing is based on a florida case
actually which says as long as you're
not using the information to prove
bad character and you're using it to
show intent or modus operandi
it's all good so if the prosecution is
able to get this in
i think it's going to be very convincing
to the jury
now dina they're trying to put them all
together three of the victims were shot
the one that hayes is charged with here
was strangled
will that make it hard for the
prosecution to tie it all in together
because of different ways of
death not necessarily 10 years
lapse between the first three and the
last one and it's not unusual to see
some sort of progression
if he is indeed a serial killer and how
he does the killings
the last one is actually more intimate
and that it is a strangulation
which also seems like consistent with
maybe how a serial killer might progress
in his killings
yeah maybe we'll see some expert talking
about the mindset of a serial killer in
this case which would be really
interesting
thank you dean and thank you terry when
we come back robert durst turns to look
at the jury
as prosecutors play testimony from a
friend who says the millionaire's
missing wife
was afraid of him the alleged ties to
the murder of his best friend
next
welcome back testimony has resumed in
the trial of a real estate air
accused of murdering his best friend to
cover up the decades-old disappearance
of his first wife
robert durst is accused of shooting
susan berman in the head execution style
in december 2000.
prosecutors say berman had information
about the disappearance of durst first
wife
kathy in 1982 and threatened to go to
the police
the defense says he didn't kill berman
and doesn't know who did
one of kathy's classmates testified at a
pre-trial hearing
in 2018 that kathy was afraid her
husband would hurt her
video of that testimony was played in
court so the now a doctor didn't have to
fly in from new york
kathy said that she was very
frightened because she thought
that her husband might hurt her and did
she say those words to you yes she did
she said that there were problems in the
marriage
and that the things that escalated to
the point that she
felt unsafe
she said that her husband was
capable of violence and told the story
to support that sit here today
are you still afraid of mr durst either
well i would say less than that it was
in 1982
but uh there's some feeling that
you know a state of mind i have a
situation that may not be
100
on cross the defense asked about kathy
durst's alleged drug use and suggested
that could have explained her behavior
back in 1981.
you said she was agitated she froze up
she
appeared to you um
uh later when she called you
her voice was shaking she was talking
fast or the meaning was upset
are those symptoms that are
also common to the use of cocaine
some of you talking fast certainly in
late
1981 which you've described to it you
didn't call it policeman
you call anybody
and then when uh you learned of that
disappearance again you did not call it
right and the first time that you called
the authority
at all was in 2003
yes all right back one last time with us
is terry and dina dina call me crazy
but is this whole dirt trial built on a
thin thin block arguing that maybe
susan berman knew about a murder that
the prosecution can't prove
isn't that built in reasonable doubt
right there
they do have to prove a case within a
case but today's testimony was very
helpful because
this classmate says that he she told him
how scared
she was of her husband and the other
thing the classmate said
was that nobody came to interview him
so it helped show two things one was
that
she had a reason to be afraid of her
husband and two the police didn't do a
very good job of investigating the case
which may be why there was never a trial
for robert durst which is important for
the jury to know
why he was never convicted if indeed he
did something with his wife
yeah maybe he slipped through the cracks
and now this is them just catching up to
him
terry bill mayor the dirt bill maher
sorry the durst neighbor
in south salem testified that robert
durst didn't stop by for drinks
after he dropped kathy off at the train
station the night of her disappearance
contradicting what doris was said all
along how does that hurt the defense
you know it's interesting dina's right
this is a case within a case and
if in fact this testimony by mr mayor
is believed by the jury it's really
going to show
that robert durst didn't have an alibi
at all i mean in fact if he stopped by
for drinks at the mayor's house then it
means he didn't have time
to kill and dispose of kathy's body and
that is in fact what robert durst i
think is trying to claim and crime
trying to show here but i think if the
jury believes
mr mayor and his wife they both said the
same thing and she also said she saw
blue light in the basement that night
i think that if the jury believes that
they're not going to believe durst at
all all right we'll see where the jury
lays when it comes to all this testimony
coming in
dina and terry thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here along
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you